tutti ragazzi per tutte questo lo vedo
io sono parigi oggi siamo con step di da
una vita e non faccio video con stefano
st 3 pn y scusa siamo su un gioco
ovviamente che conoscete tutti che rende
giustizia a questa coppia
buona visione e sono un po turbato deve
essere semplice allora tu con f prendi
le rocce e devi lanciarle in faccia a me
ok ok però eh eh eh basta è finito
questo gioco
ho finito di spiegare e poi risparmi su
una roccia capite crisponi su una rolls
royce e poi c'è una roccia bianca che se
colpisci con quella è finita la partita
hai vinto dopo il boccino d'oro di harry
potter è capito io ho preso sotto le
gambe non ti è successo niente eh no
perché riprende mi in testa così è morto
non alzerà la roccia bianca se tu hai la
roccia bianca spettatori vita dei
ragazzi allenati sicuro c'è bianca se
colpisci anche se ti ho fatto fuori
villa volte lo colpisci con quella e
veniva camerieri c'è un tempo
boh credo siano di essi c'è un tempo di
tre minuti mi stai facendo già troppe
domande che non alle quali non sono
risposte quindi basta il profitto di
spiegare questa giornata poi è più tra
l'altro se ti avvicinò se ti avvicini
tantissimo al nemico ma tom poi ecco ci
siamo abbracciati morti tra l'altro non
è le volte in cui fai fuori una persona
che determina il punteggio non so come
mai alle volte fai fuori più di più la
persona ma alla fine vince l'altro non
sì sì no no quella no se io mica c'è una
gara incredibile tiro cittadino
ne ho sentita nel deretano nel dal vivo
non usiamo la bianca e società dovrà
fare a meno che non è vero siamo in
maniera labianca no ho preso e finisce
qui non è vero ma ti calmati comunque
migliorate ma tra l'altro non e non sono
mai stato si prova per la gente vale 100
se pensa quali sono due tra i campi
panico il cile d'oro allora la via è
perché l'hanno messa recentemente non
c'era bianca proibita ahia ahia ahia
adesso non ci becchiamo più perché
capito me si gioca cosa già io
maledizione bello o madonna è un missile
della nasa che più la donna non vado al
38 che non sia bianca qua e no sono
tutte così occhio a pugni una botta
incredibile ma sparato fuori
ok con ha posto però no no lasciata lì
alla nostra madonna meno male ho giocato
lato
non saliva è laggiù across the map
ecco la risposta è sì è rimasta sola la
quindi vai
[Musica]
perché ho aspettato tutto il tempo che
la tirasse da qualche parte perché
pensavo a trevi tassi un movement e
invece l'ha tirata dritta dopo un ora
bella bella mi è piaciuta perché il velo
chiamo ci sono mappe piatti ai aires
meno male che non mi sono dato che sma
lotta dei crediti l'ha poi lasciata la
puoi lasciare con hicks l'ho scoperto
adesso pare predictor vista roccia è
niente ho sbagliato
uno dei due è aiuto madonna mi ha dato
tantissimo problema che mi avete
veramente preso un sacco la spalla
contro spalla vado a casa sempre io qua
ma infatti è strana sta cosa cioè non ho
mai capito che funziona la spalla contro
spalla
allora ciò che esponi lì no non è vero
dove minchia si suona addio ma non sono
riuscito a spostarmi buy ed esiste bene
al carla boto brand sarebbero fuori e la
puoi prendere dal tas e se ti impegni
correndo fuori anno ma ce n'è un'altra
qua mi fa tornare indietro e lo so se
premio f nel momento giusto per la
prendo uguale su lungo uomo way ma era
un chilometro qua a sono rimanere
sbrozzi ok due rocce possono prenderlo o
madonna livello 1 si gira in arrivo a un
meteorite arrivo arrivo il popper dove
aiuto ma donna che correva per com'è
possibile
se sfornando qua quello che non si può
prendere la bianca che veramente troppo
fuori quindi è una presa allo che non
moriamo madonna che cambia marginati ed
armi in pugno fortissimo di tv c'era
la visita questa non avevamo in senso
dai favole l'ultima l'ultima meno male
che gratis perché poteva anche essere a
pagamento c'è stato pure perche non ci
luca non è anche un pochino neanche un
po tirata l'espansione questa 10 euro
veramente porre come 13 euro giusto
gioco però ottimo ottima partenza
aggiungerei che non ci aiuta anche se
sei qua ma proprio dietro di me
rinascere con tutte le rocce che ci sono
madonna bianca ho visto male aiuto
premiano fortissima e più sempre il
fight corpo corpo so che si sfondano
limano suscita mccarthy lo stesso
ecco mai come key to speech
ecco fatto oddio capitali dalla
traiettoria sempre i modi aiuto
madonna questa dello spogliatoio trilla
eccoci minchiate potenza arriva non ho
paura proprio mai preso tantissimo ma
avevo preso da qui sono due volte è
veramente preso una mia la prima mi ha
trapassato veramente non so come sia
possibile e fatto agli preso roccia in
faccia da fallibile avevo capito lo
sfogo ma non sei riuscito a fattivo
aiuto vero non è più e lo a destra
ero al best gioco infame l'ho pagato da
sì perché scrivo perché le altre rocce
normali contro la bianca oddio oddio
buono ma come tu mancata
ecco o no sei disponi qui
vuoi andare la bianca io lo so noi come
come così aiuto mentre scolari dai
questa proprio in next level gaming dai
basta dire che basta così gioco è una
pezza
i ragazzi questa è la pau la plancia the
youtuber la nostra pancia ragazzi si è
toccata perché la pancia mia distefano m
finisco di cagate la finiamo lidl
caricate dai basta però che vi sia
piaciuto con questo video non ha un
senso ma volevo trovare un gioco che
rendesse giustizia e stefano mi ha
accompagnato sono molto contento niente
passate da canal di stefano mi mando un
bacio era come sei
[Musica]